the biggest difference between you and
the people who you look up to are that
they started and you're still thinking
about it it's one of the most
frustrating things in helping
entrepreneurs that I deal with on a
day-to-day basis is that seeing so much
potential in people seeing so much heart
and love and care is like you could be
serving so much and helping so much and
having such a big impact and we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the perfect cameraman my
first video if you go back and watch my
channel I had my friend come and film it
and record it for me because I was
worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup And I memorized
the script because they didn't want to
say the wrong words I had to be perfect
most of my early videos were voice over
because I could write a script and have
it perfect and just have b-roll and it
wouldn't be me on camera afraid of
making mistake and saying the wrong
things and messing up I was too afraid
to do the next thing I was too afraid to
get in the race I was making content at
least I was one decent thing for
whatever reason I stay consistent on on
doing stuff but I was afraid to say The
Next Step the big step to go off and do
it and a lot of you are already way
better than than I was when I started
this is the thing that kills me the most
it's like the hearts like you want
you've got such a good heart you want to
do so much and then there's just no
action there's no momentum because of
the fear neat motivation watch a top 10
with the believe Nation hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we made these videos
probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of much more and you
get that Push by surrounding yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and our take of his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
if you can make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
or the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going
so when people ask me should I should I
do this business or this business should
I do that business or this one's like
well I don't know you know like at the
end of the day it's gonna be what you
love doing all of them could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's going to be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like coffee or not you know you have to
go off and you take a sip
and then you find out you can't think
your way through this so you can't think
your way you can have some planning but
your planning won't save you at the end
of the day you have to go off and just
do something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so
let's make it practical let me just give
you some steps for how to actually get
in the race and start taking some action
step one
understand
or at least tell yourself that great
ideas flow through you
great ideas flow through you that
because you came up with the idea that
it's a good idea stop judging and stop
telling yourself you suck stop telling
yourself someone like you can't do it
like great ideas flow through you this
is a good idea you need to go do
something about it right even just
telling yourself that shortcuts is the
fear because all of the reasons in your
head for why you can't do it is really
just fear if you think about making
content and you're worried about the
microphone and the camera and the gear
and all that that's just fear talking
it's just you're afraid that it won't be
good and so you're trying to cover your
bases and we come up with all these
logical reasons why we can't do it but
really just fear talking so cut through
the fear by telling yourself that great
ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later still stuck in the
same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us are are stuck in an
action because we're Paralyzed by fear
and we've come up with rational reasons
why we can't do the thing rule number
two develop discipline discipline is
your missing ingredient you you've got
the heart you've got the care you've got
the desire to serve you know you could
be doing more you want to do it for the
right reasons you're not just here to
make money you're here to have an impact
in the grow and do amazing things you
know you can do amazing things what's
missing discipline
this is a lack to follow through it's
the constant start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reasons why I'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post my socials
of how I grew month over month year over
year on YouTube and in the first five
years I had seven thousand subscribers
or so
five years in five years in of making
content
seven thousand subscribers a lot of you
already ahead of that a lot of you could
get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
in 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and secure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
beliefs all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me
I remember sitting down at a
um Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my industry it was
in music I'm going to be the next
garyvee in music and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
it let's me you know let's let's keep in
touch and see how we do and how we grow
and he posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the host and I told him I was
gonna be the next garyvee for music and
he's gonna do keep doing his thing and
and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's super
talented in music and just better camera
presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff all
of it
the only thing you lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough it's the it's the lack of
because you're not motivated you stop
and lack of motivation isn't a good
enough reason you have to follow through
rule number three change your
environment the fastest way to change
your habits is to change your
environment you ever notice how when
you're in a different environment maybe
you go on vacation maybe you go to an
event or seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you've ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well it's
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars or those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too this morning I was talking to a
YouTuber big YouTuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different Niche and I remember meeting
him in California
a couple years ago and one of the things
he was struggling with was staying
consistent and I'm very consistent and
one of the things I was struggling with
was staying healthy while I was on the
road and we're having dinner together
and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and I probably had a burger or something
fries and
coming away from that what I realized
was
whoever is more confident wins and when
you're around other people whoever's
more confident in the habit that they
have will be the dominant habit that
both of you end up picking up so if we
were hanging out together more here's
what would happen I would become a lot
healthier in my eating and he would
become a lot more consistent in his
content because we'd be inspired by each
other because he'd see me working with
make my videos and he'd feel bad that he
was making his and he'd have to go and
start making his and I see him eating
healthy all the time and be like man I
should be eating healthy and they would
force me to do it as well that
environment switch would allow us to
create much better stronger habits so
now you got to be careful about the kind
of people who you're hanging out with
and if you look at the people you've got
right now around you chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them support
pouring into them you're taking your cup
and pointing to them and it's great and
it's and you should keep doing that and
it's amazing and it's it's fulfilling
but who's pointing to you and who's
making you get to the next step because
if you don't have that you're gonna
you're gonna continue to stay small or
just have slow growth compared to where
you could be so how do we get some
practical steps okay that's great what
do we actually do how do you start
making that change happen well the first
step is to figure out what is it that
you want to get better at you know what
area of your life or business do you
want to be better at is it you want to
stay more consistent on your habits you
want to you want to learn how to make
money you want to have a better
relationship you want to take care of
your health like what is the thing that
you actually want to get better on
getting Clarity on what that thing is
two is to then surround yourself as much
as possible with
with content not even people because it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around Joe dispense all the time and you
will you will become better you will
meditate more you will solve your
awesome but you don't know Joe dispenza
and he's probably not taking on students
right now or mentees right or Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever right you
don't know them and so that's not a
practical answer but you can hang around
their content
that's why I make these videos every day
because if every day there was a new
video for you hopefully it lifts you to
bring some of the best experts in the
world the people that I find inspiring
and learn from to share their message
every morning you don't have that person
in your life but there's videos for you
so step two is step one we're figuring
out what is it that we want right where
do we want to improve and get better
step two is who are the people who are
who are living it who are preaching it
who are living it who actually inspire
you and there's so many different people
out there who are doing it and everybody
has their own way I like to say that you
know an Aaron Thomas is going to yell at
you through it and Oprah Winfrey is
going to hug you through it but they
have very similar messages
whoever style you connect with the most
have that more consistently in your
environment follow them on Instagram
subscribe to them on YouTube put their
quotes on the wall around you create
your own environment of the people who
make you feel like you want to do more
to inspire you to step out of your
comfort zone and take on those new
habits that you want to actually adopt
right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with Joe dispenza or Elon
musker Oprah Winfrey
okay so I call them aspirational mentors
and and that can be fundamental and
that's where most people need to start
because you have access to their books
and their videos and their content you
have that access right now and that can
make a big shift in you if you start
surrounding yourself with it every day
and then step three is to is to get more
in-person connections and this is more
time consuming and more challenging and
harder to find the right fits but
can make a big shift as well in your
life so I don't want to only rely on
that's why step two is actually having
just content that you're learning from
but step three if there's people that
you're learning from do they have an
event do they have something coming up
can you hang around people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges I'm doing a challenge right
now inside my movement makers program
where Movie Makers is For Thought
leaders who are trying to get to the
next level with their content and break
through and have a greater message and
reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have because
they're the only ones doing this they
don't know anybody else making content
their family thinks they're crazy like
why are you making another video they're
not seeing results that they don't have
a peer group they don't have anybody to
connect with and talk to and
this can relate to any goal that you
have movement makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our movement makers challenge
is every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to start
making content and for a lot of the
members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though a lot of the content
that you make
um outside will still be separate from
the members you're not doing a business
together but it feels like they're
connected we're taking on this challenge
together and then in the collaboration
videos you're you're connecting with
people you're doing interviews with
people you're you're sharing your
thoughts and feedback it's not just you
talking to a camera in the car with your
dogs by yourself anymore
[Laughter]
matters it really really matters so
getting some kind of support group
connecting with other people who are on
the same Journey going to seminars or
events of of humans that you can talk to
and connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do because the more
that you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life
it's it's entirely possible and if
you're watching videos like this you're
you're already on the growth mindset
Journey right you're already into
personal development you already know
you want to do more and serve more and
help more and this helps you elevate
yourself to the next level because you
are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can one clearly
identify what you want to change what is
the Habit that you want to take on where
are you not satisfied anymore in your
life not beating yourself up and saying
you suck but like the next level of
growth that you want to accomplish
yourself and then two following people
just through content who are living that
message who are who are not just
speaking it but living it who who when
you watch their their videos you
actually get inspired to go make a
change in your life who are those people
subscribe to them follow them every day
watch their content read their books put
their stuff up on your wall as a
reminder you're creating a new
environment for yourself and then three
is actually connecting with humans
joining a group like Movie Makers or
something else going to events where
your your tribe is at so that you are
not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like you don't belong make
those three changes it will change your
life the difference between where you
are now where you could be it's just the
consistent habits that you're putting in
you know this I know you know this now
it's about taking the actual action to
stay consistent on those habits rule
number four use challenges to grow your
challenges don't only make you stronger
they allow you to serve better I think
the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that I put in your way allow you to have
a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and the
thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor to build to serve you are
built to serve when you can connect the
challenge that you're going through as
something that's then going to inspire
and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do
as opposed to just being about me
getting stronger I find a lot of times
me getting stronger is not enough it's
not enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour of 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
was my first ever tour and then I broke
my neck two-thirds of the way through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in an insane amounts of pain I have
a concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not so I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
is great for speaking but sucks for
everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believing you're not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash uh we're we're next so we're
probably gonna get some crazy noise we
have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time look
we're next you guys can see this is this
car wash we're next depending on how
long that guy ahead of us takes you
might you might see it in this video I
dealt with a lot of those mindset issues
those lack of belief issues those
worthiness issues and I I battled them
and I've been through them and
have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did and the path
can be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
uh I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
times like a light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five associate with
inspiring people the reason why you're
not following through is because you're
doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely but this is
the life of an entrepreneur this is why
so many great entrepreneurs don't follow
through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it
but I have a really low maybe it's just
introverted or or uh what it whatever
but I just don't need it as much as most
people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you
know you get to pick everything you want
but then to go from having a job where
you have Community even if it even if
you didn't enjoy the work you were doing
which you got from the job if you've had
one is community that you had co-workers
and you had some people who you did like
and you had people to go to lunch with
and you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
yeah okay great yeah you just tore my
heart open Evan now what do I do how do
I fix it well first is just recognizing
that that is a problem you know first is
recognizing that there's nothing wrong
with you there's nothing wrong with you
you're amazing the only problem is you
just don't have anybody that you're
collaborating with that you're doing
this by yourself so the answer is we
need to now go and find other people to
collaborate with so one recognizing that
this is a problem and you need to fix it
two is in finding a group that you can
be a part of and what we tend to do as
entrepreneurs is lead we want to lead we
want to create groups we want to build
we want to make
oh I would actually advocate for joining
a group
one you don't need another thing on your
plate to lead you've got enough already
that you have to worry about and two
when you're the leader of it it puts you
in a slightly different position where
it's nice just to participate
you know it's nice just to have somebody
else be in charge and you just get to
show up
and and be a part of it
so I would look for a community that you
could join
where it's where it's your people it's
people like you who are trying to do
similar things
I look at movement makers as an example
and whether you want to join Movie
Makers or or you know find your own
group amazing but movement makers I
started
as a way for me to help train up and
coming thought leaders you know it was
the initial goals like hey I can only
reach I want to tell the world's biggest
problem right people don't believe in
themselves enough not everybody's gonna
learn through my story but they might be
able to learn through yours your message
your story your history your way of
looking at it the thing that you went
through I haven't gone through until
that by definition allows you to reach
people that I can't that Tony Robbins
can't that Jay Shetty can't that whoever
Oprah can't right your story can reach
people in a way that others can't and so
I want to give you the skills to be able
to go off and reach those people that's
why I started Movie Makers what I
realized getting through it is the
skills alone Aren't Enough the skills
are not the main reason why people are
not following through
you already have a lot of skills you
know it's not where you want to be but
you have a lot of skills and you have a
lot of heart so if you take somebody
with a lot of skills and a lot of heart
and they're still not following through
what's the problem
you're doing it alone
you're lonely and it's really hard to do
it when you're lonely so I shifted
movement makers to still BS skills and
training and techniques and strategies
and I realized that people were winning
when they connected to each other
and at the start I was doing all the
connection like oh I know this person's
doing this and this person's doing that
and so I should connect those two people
together
and I was and that was creating that's
created businesses it's created podcasts
together that's created opportunities
for people but it still was limited on
me connecting people together where I
wanted to make it that people would
connect to each other without me
and that's what we've ended up doing in
Movie Makers
one of the things I'm most proud of is
we started a challenge and again whether
I don't care if you join movement makers
or not great to have you but this
concept you can apply to your business
we started the challenge where
I was giving people the tactics and
telling them what to do and that they
still weren't doing the follow-through
and the follow-through would be making
content making videos right you want to
be a thought leader you got to get your
message out there
so I started a challenge and we started
the first one I think back in October so
now we're into our fifth challenge or so
where here's a challenge you have to
make one video
one lead magnet and three collaboration
videos around the theme so the theme
might be momentum or impact or believe
or belong
um we pick a different theme every month
but something everybody can talk to
right the theme was impact you can talk
to impact within the thing that you do
and by forcing them to collaborate with
three other people in the group
it really led to a situation where one
plus one equals a thousand
because
by forcing yourself to show up for
somebody else
it made sure that you followed through
where all of a sudden now people who who
hadn't made a single video who might
have been a movie makers for three
months and still never made a video now
they're making their first videos now
they're making the first lead magnets
now they're making their first solo
videos suddenly they have
some follow-through
and suddenly the fears and the excuses
will weigh because they're connected to
other people when you're doing something
with somebody else there's energy there
there's momentum there and you're much
more likely to follow through
so you have to go and get a tribe
find people who are like you who have a
similar Mission if you look at mover
makers
everybody's mission is is different in
the sense that they're trying to serve
different people but everybody's
connected in that we want to have an
impact we have a story that matters and
we want to share it with the world
that's everybody in the group
the types of people trying to reach are
different
and so when you are
by yourself you're the only one in your
family trying to do what you do you're
the one pouring into other people right
you're probably the most happy
optimistic positive person you're
encouraging the people around you you're
pouring into their cups great keep doing
that but who's helping you with that
when you feel low when you feel down
when you feel not worthy when you feel
not good enough who's pouring in you to
say hey let's go do this thing together
nobody right your friends maybe I mean
if you're lucky and you have some great
friends might be empathetic might be
encouraging to you but they're not doing
the thing that you're doing they don't
understand what you're going through
they could they could give you some
words of affirmation and encouragement
but they don't know how to actually help
where if you're going through a journey
with somebody else with a group of
people you're just much more likely to
follow through
and feel connected
and feel special and feel like you
matter
so Step One is recognize that there's
nothing wrong with you
you're amazing you've got the heart
you've got the dream you've got the the
ability to serve
unsept two is and go find your tribe go
find people who are like you
who you see on your calendar and you're
excited to go meet with them and connect
whether it's Movie Makers or something
totally separate
but don't do this alone
if you could make one change this year
for the next 12 months
to have the significant impact on the
growth of your journey
commit to just not doing this by
yourself
and watch everything in your life get
better rule number six think bank if you
want to make more money you want to make
big money you have to start thinking on
a bigger scale
and that might sound obvious as I say it
but recognizing your own limiting
thinking where you're playing small is
one of the most challenging things to do
I think in the world I am where I'm at
because I'm also I've thought big enough
but also I'm not at a higher level
because I'm not thinking bigger period
it's really hard and so here's a quick
example there was uh two days ago I was
talking to an entrepreneur friend of
mine and he's built he's built a decent
business inside of one year he's got a
quarter Million Dollar business right
that's a pretty good business for for
one year and he went from
you know being let go from his job and
starting this company and now he's at a
quarter million in revenue and he
messages me just as a fun thing to do
and it's like hey I'm doing a points run
where should I go
the cape you could fly anywhere where
would you go on a points run like what's
a points run and he said I'm I'm
qualifying for uh one of the airlines to
get a certain level a certain tier with
them and I need to get a certain number
of points so that I can qualify to get
in and said oh I don't know I don't I
pay zero attention to that if you're
thinking about going somewhere
instead of flying this is how you
upgrade this is how you make more money
right it's upgrading the thinking he's
trying to solve the problem of I need to
get into the Points Club so that I can I
can get whatever marginal benefits from
being in that club
and I said you know what you should be
thinking of instead of flying economy to
some city that is however many miles
away you need to get your points what
you should be doing is thinking how do I
make it worth my time to fly somewhere
where I can afford to fly business class
and land a five-figure deal as a result
of being there
he's got
a couple clients right now that if he
could go and visit them we were just on
on a call and he's talking about how one
of his clients is having a hard time
figuring out a standard operating
procedure of how they should be applying
the knowledge he's given them and and
train their team on how to do it right
that that was a problem that just came
up for them like we love what you're
telling us we love your offering we're
having a hard time executing it and
making it standard procedure
the next call that he's doing with them
was going to be to train them and how to
do it great hey instead of thinking
about a points run how about you go fly
there
and say you know what I'll spend a day
with you
sitting down training you on how to do
this
this is a client that is already made
five people client a year for him that
could easily become a low six-figure
client a year for him so he could more
than double the business
if they execute on his ideas right
because he's not in there doing all the
work but this could this could more than
double his business with this one client
with with no real extra added cost or
expense to him just pure income at the
top
so instead of hopping on the zoom call
with them and training them and going
back and forth on email how about you
fly there spend a day with them build
the relationship even deeper with them
because he's never actually met them in
person
and that way you you take your points
run you still get your points and
qualify for whatever discounts you get
and benefits you can fly business class
there have a much better experience and
end up doubling the business with your
client and getting an extra five six
figures as a result of it like this is
the upgrade in the thinking you want to
make bigger money you have to start
thinking about bigger thinking and I
fully acknowledge that I'm not thinking
big enough for where I want to go you
know every time I
I think I'm thinking big I'll watch a
Grant Cardone video or I'll watch an
Elon Musk video and Elon Musk is talking
about having a backup plan for the
planet that's why we're going to Mars I
watch a Steve Jobs video of taking a
dent in the universe and I realize oh my
gosh I'm thinking so small you know I'm
doing nothing not in a bad way in an
inspiring positive way to say man you
could be doing so much more come on man
let's go
so it's still my biggest problem too
it's the hardest thing to catch
because for him
and his environment and his friends and
how he grew up
a points run is is correct thinking you
know getting the discount codes is the
right thinking
the challenge with that is you're
spending time looking for the best deal
and looking to save a hundred dollars
here or a couple hundred dollars there
and you're using your mental energy up
on small problems
what my friend is doing is using his
mental energy up on trying to save a
couple thousand dollars when he could be
adding six figures to his business with
the same mental energy
now luckily you know he brought it up
and I was able to call him out on it and
and suggest a better path forward
if he hadn't it it was a joke I think
when he sent it like where would I where
should I go on a points run
I don't think he expected the answer
that I gave him but I think the only way
to to get this is to be around the
people who can call it out in you either
physically I think that's the best the
challenge is it's as you as you get
bigger as you grow more there's fewer
people who are ahead of you who can push
you
right there's fewer people who can look
at what you're doing and say hey this is
nothing play bigger in a loving way like
push you in a loving way as you climb
the ladder there's very there's fewer
and fewer people at the top of the
ladder who are ahead of you right and so
yes you want to give back and you want
to serve and as you learn you reach back
and you pull somebody else up to your
level but constantly finding somebody
that's why I love
um
I love Mastermind groups I love coaching
I love tapping into experts on different
topics because they pull me up
uh even if I'm an expert at something I
want to talk to my friends who are
experts and people who are ahead of me
because they push me to be better and if
you don't know those people yet
what are your options well you could
join group programs
right I've got for example movement
makers I love my movement makers program
it's 49 bucks a month and we meet every
two weeks and you get to learn from me
and there's other amazing humans who are
trying to build up their platforms as
well and become thought leaders and
experts but if it's not my program
there's tons of other programs out there
who do you connect with who do you love
who do you look up to and you get a
little bit of you may not be able to
afford to fly there and meet them but
you can learn from them even in a group
setting if you can't afford that you
know 49 bucks a month or 97 bucks a
month or whatever the programs are is
too much for you then even the free
content even even what I'm doing even
these videos here
you get a little bit from some super
successful person every time I make a
video if you even just consistently
watch those I've learned a ton from Elon
Musk and and uh Jeff Bezos and Steve
Jobs and people who I've never met
through my own videos and they push me
and they challenge me they can't
specifically call me out they can't say
hey Evan what you're doing right here
this thing that you're doing like the
points run is small right you shouldn't
be doing that but they can at least give
me encouragement and motivation in in
seeing what they're doing inspires me to
want to do something bigger rule number
seven serve others when you are
accountable to other people you are more
likely to follow through whether it's in
entrepreneurship whether it's in
personal development whether it's
working out or working on yourself when
you are feeling like somebody else is
counting on you besides you you're way
more like to follow through think about
going to the gym right you may not like
going to the gym
you may find reasons to put off going to
gym maybe it's early morning maybe
you're tired you didn't sleep well last
night your muscle still hurt from
yesterday all sorts of reasons and
excuses you come up with but if you know
that somebody else is going to be there
your friend is going to be there waiting
for you
you're way more likely to follow through
because now it's not just about you I
created a challenge inside my Movie
Makers program and movement makers is a
program I created to help thought
leaders experts who want to build up
their following and want to get their
message out to the world you got a big
message in here let's get out to the
world and you train with me but you also
get to connect with each other and I was
frustrated that people were not making
enough content you've got such a big
message such a big potential voice your
story matters and people were not making
enough content and everybody was living
not everybody but a good chunk of people
were living inside the typical reasons
we all come up with right too busy I
don't know what gear to use I I don't
like how I look on camera my videos suck
over and over and over you know the same
reasons and so I decided to do something
a couple months ago that was different I
said you know what we are going to do a
challenge because the thing that's
missing is momentum
do you guys have the heart and the soul
and the care just like
if you ever meet anybody in Movie Makers
it's just good people
hmm some of the nicest friendliest most
caring most giving people that I've ever
met you've got everything
you're just missing momentum
you're just not putting that up there
because there's there's too many there's
too much blockage in your head
you need momentum
and so out of that frustration I came up
with the momentum Challenge and my goal
with the momentum challenge was
for them to make content but not just
make content actually
create the content in a way that can
generate business for them so
the challenge was structured in five
pieces of the content one was a solo
video and the theme was momentum so you
have to make a solo video on momentum
two is three collaboration videos with
other people in movement makers so you
need to do an interview with somebody
and collaborate on the theme of momentum
and then the third thing was to do a
lead magnet on momentum so lead magnet
basically implies that you create a PDF
or you create a unlisted video that you
can share in return for people giving
you their email address so they email
you you get you give them the PDF and
now they're on your email list and you
can use that to continue to build a
relationship and ultimately work with
them hopefully in some capacity right
where you're serving caring and making
money in the process too
says that that's a challenge
and whoever's in
you have the whole month to do it
and at the end of the month whoever
completes the challenge
we're gonna do a clubhouse live all
together and celebrate
I didn't know how it would go
you know like I hope I hope people would
take me up on it but it's easy to have a
lot of excitement at the beginning right
every have you ever been excited by
something at the beginning and then
pretty quickly in you fall off the
tracks right has that ever happened to
you we're talking about a month here
it's not just make one video today it's
you got to stay consistent for a month
you gotta make five pieces of content in
a month and for a lot of people
didn't know how to do collaborations
never done an interview with somebody
else for a lot of people that didn't
know what a lead magnet was or how to
make one or how to save a PDF or how to
set up a landing page how to do all the
tech behind the scenes right and those
are the excuses that they were
holding on to for why they couldn't win
in their own business but now it's being
forced now you have to do it and I
didn't know how well it would work out
and
fortunately it went insanely well
people had some of the best conversation
of their lives people finally got the
tech side of their business figured out
with landing pages and Lead magnets
people started forming alliances and
Partnerships and cooperations and joint
ventures with each other that I'd never
even anticipated or seen
why because they were committing to each
other
because now it wasn't just about doing
it for themselves it was about doing it
with somebody
and here's what's important it's not
just doing it by yourself or for
somebody
it's doing it with somebody that makes a
big difference because if you're
watching this channel you're probably
heart driven entrepreneur right that's
why I love you it's why you're here
you're a heart-driven entrepreneur you
want to serve you want to make money you
want to have an impact right it's not
just about the dollars but also putting
something positive out into the world
that you're proud of whether it's making
content like this or products or
Services you want to serve you are built
to serve it's why you're here and I love
that
and so you can connect to the mission
and the service because you're doing it
for somebody right you're doing it for
your audience you're doing it for your
customers you're doing it for the people
who are going to consume what you're
creating
that's very different though than doing
it with somebody because most
entrepreneurs and and this is a good gut
check or look in the mirror for yourself
most entrepreneurs are doing it by
themselves even if you have a team you
still feel like you're doing it by
yourself there's nobody who actually
gets what you do does that sound
familiar
do you feel like you're kind of alone on
this people who support you or might cue
you on but they're not in the same boat
they're not trying to do what you do
they don't know how to help besides
giving some words of encouragement
so you feel like you're doing it by
yourself and man is it hard to do
something that's hard when you're by
yourself and that's where you need the
mental toughness and a discipline and
the scheduling and the calendar and the
and you do hard things
and one of the best hacks to make sure
you actually follow through is you have
some accountability
and not just somebody to just to hold
your feet to the fire to say hey you
know what are you doing you know you
don't need a boss
but you need to feel like you're doing
this with people
are you doing your thing but with others
and I think that's where the movement
makers challenge just really played out
super well is that now all of a sudden
people are booking collaborations with
each other and they know what to talk
about where before they wouldn't they
wouldn't book an interview because they
didn't know what questions to ask
people are now helping each other with
their landing pages and Lead magnets
where in the past they would tell
themselves I don't know the tech I'm too
confused I need to hire somebody but I
have no money to hire somebody and now
all of a sudden they're getting it done
now it's happening where months or a
year might have gone by and they still
hadn't done it now all of a sudden
there's momentum happening
why because they committed to somebody
else and because they committed to the
group
that they want to complete this thing
and then the celebration when we did our
our clubhouse at the end of the month
the stories and the emotion was just so
amazing it became movement makers
started as me sharing a message I'm
going to teach you how to XYZ and it
became so much more about the family and
the community and the connection that
really people are following through not
just because of the ideas that I'm
giving them but because they have a
group of people that they're doing this
thing with
so find your own group
you know or find one person I have a
something I remind myself of constantly
that I like to collect good people
I want to find good people I want to be
around good people I want to be around
the people who fill me up who make me
feel like I'm worthy I can do great
things make me energized I leave them
feeling better about myself than than
when I came in I want to be around those
people and when I find somebody like
that I wanted I want to fight to find
more time with them
and as an introverted chai person that
can be really difficult and awkward and
I'm still afraid to ask for help and I
probably still don't do that enough
somebody I there was a speaker who I
spoke at his event and uh he's like how
can I help you I was like I don't know
I'm here to serve you know I wanted to
help no problem you know but and he
wrote back said no I I owe you like how
can I help you and and it's still
something I'm working on and doing a
better job and asking for help because
I'll default to him
find the solution myself don't want to
don't want to burden people you know
it's the story that is in my head that I
need to fix but when you can find people
to do something with when you are on
your path and you feel alone and you're
struggling and the motivation isn't
there but then you know that somebody
else is on the same Journey with you
you're so much more likely to follow
through
and so I encourage you not to do this
alone not to live life alone not to run
your business alone that you'll have a
greater degree of Joy Of Happiness of
impact of service of momentum of of
progress of results
when you have people
even one person
who you feel like you're doing this with
so don't
try to be the hero all the time and feel
like you have to do everything yourself
don't think well I'm doing this for
people and that that's enough
make it a goal
of yours
that in the next 30 days you're gonna
find somebody who's gonna help hold you
a little bit accountable and you're
gonna hold them accountable too
you're giving just as much as you're
taking
and together you're going to create
something amazing it's it's a true
scenario where one plus one equals 14.
you plus them equals tremendous growth
for both of you
you don't have to do this alone
get somebody to help you stay
accountable rule number eight keep
making progress with a push past failure
is to keep making progress
part of the reasons why you stick on
failure and feeling so bad about
yourself and it's never going to work
out it's because there's nothing new
that you're working on that's exciting
that you're building towards that you
feel like you're making progress on
because when you're making progress and
you're moving forward you can't feel
like a failure and you don't have time
to think about the failures that you've
had
people ask me all the time hey what do
you do when one of your videos fail
my bad
on the analytics and show hey when this
happened your video tank yes and we do
that and we learn from it but I don't
have time to sit there and look at
all of just the failures and sit on it
because I've got more videos that I need
to make another video is coming out
tomorrow and another videos come out the
next day another videos come out the
next day and I don't know how many
videos we put out every day across all
of our channels but it's a lot of
content and I'm so focused on the next
thing that I'm less focused on the one
that was so learn from that awesome now
move forward and when you don't have
anything that you're moving forward
towards that's when it starts to really
hit hard and so that's
I think it's really important I think we
get too caught up on our first one and
it being amazing and nobody liking it
and so we're gonna stop and and even for
me my first video I figured how many
months it was between my first video of
all time and then my second video but it
but it was a while before I kept going
because the first video didn't do as
well as I thought I I would do uh I
wasn't as good as I thought it was gonna
be I was way more nervous than I thought
it was going to be and I got no comments
right it's like my mom and my sister
commented on my video and I felt like a
failure so I stopped going
and the thing that saved me the most
over however many years of making videos
the decade plus has been you keep going
you keep making content you keep
creating you put it in your calendar and
you keep doing something to build
momentum towards a dream that you want
and so I think that's incredibly
valuable whether you're going through a
big failure or a mini failure I think it
helps when I look at big failures in my
life right so a video failing that's a
small failure right like this if this
video doesn't go and blow up it's a
small failure but big failures the two
biggest ones was one personal and one
business the business one is my in my
first company we I quit I'm a business
partner I just I felt like a loser I was
not making money writing making 300
bucks a month having no results no
traction I just feel like a total
failure and nothing was working out and
I told my business partner that I quit
and the thing that got me through it was
eventually just realizing hey somebody
else has done this
I can model success and I looked at Bill
Gates and how he started Microsoft and I
learned from that and built my company
but it was the the progress that moving
forward instead of being stuck on how
everything sucks and I suck and I'm not
getting results and I'm just failing the
thing that got me the energy to keep
going was
feeling like this progress towards a new
idea or a new strategy to help me
accomplish my goals my biggest personal
failure was getting divorced over 10
years ago and that was that was really
rough you know it was a personal it felt
like a personal failure I mean it ended
up being the best thing for both of us
but at the time it felt like a huge
failure even just saying that I you know
am divorced
um it just felt like a a giant failure
that I suck as a human that that I
couldn't make this work and
that took a while to get through and
eventually the thing that
that helped me was
I I pulled up a dating app and I saw uh
options you know I was like oh you know
what okay this could maybe maybe this
could work or or that could work and
it's like
idea of progress
towards something instead of being stuck
in the past is the thing that started to
get me through to build some momentum
understand that if you're living in
Failure right now it's it's just the
past you're living in the past you're
you're frustrated with what what
happened and what you should have done
differently and could have done
differently and you wish you said this
or did that or acted a certain way
you're just constantly repeating the
past where to get out of the past to get
out of failure now we need to think
present and future what are we working
towards what are we building towards
what are we creating and making and as
soon as you can shift from past to
present or future that starts to allow
your your brain to shift into forward
momentum and progress instead of living
in Failure so some of the steps that you
you can do that I think can help one
put activity into your calendar
so whatever you're working towards if it
didn't work out once awesome put in your
calendar to keep going
today's a Tuesday as I'm filming this
video Tuesday is my video day I'm I'm
making content on Tuesday
you know we're here we're sitting in the
parking lot my my wife Nina is running
some errands doing shipping out some
built to serve books I believe right now
here at the shipping center and I'm
making content because it's in my
calendar if I didn't have content day
and it wasn't scheduled in I wouldn't be
making content I'd be doing something
else or I might be thinking about all
the past failures that I had in my
content but because it's a scheduled in
my calendar I'm making progress and
moving forward so whatever you want to
make progress and move forward towards
have chunks of time in your calendar
dedicated to doing it two have something
that inspires you it could be people it
could be remembering what impact you're
trying to have your big mission or your
vision you're trying to accomplish one
of the things that really helped me
early in my career is I made a
PowerPoint file of all the people who
came to my events my my seminars uh my
speaking gigs and
the message that they had for me they
wrote to me because I feel great the
next day after an event but then I would
I would lose the vibe and lose the
momentum that didn't feel like who cares
it doesn't matter anymore but I would I
would watch his PowerPoint file where I
put their quotes on how much of an
impact that was having on them and so it
reminded me of why I do what I do and
gave me more energy momentum to keep
moving forward that becomes critical
like what inspires you to want to move
forward maybe it's watching videos like
this maybe it's looking at testimonials
from the people who who you've helped
maybe it's remembering your big goal and
dream of what you're trying to
accomplish but what inspires you to want
to start building some momentum and then
three model success and find the people
who are doing the thing or have done the
thing that you're trying to do and learn
from them and study them and what that
does is it gives you
hope and strategies
when you are studying people who've done
the thing that you want to do it gives
you the hope that it's possible for you
too right because when you look at their
story they probably started with less
than what you have right now and in
studying them you can see oh if they
could do it maybe I can too it's just
that hope because you don't see anybody
in your family your friend's Circle
doing what you want to do and so it
feels impossible but when you're around
the people who are doing it even just by
reading their book or watching their
videos it gives you the hope that it's
possible and then two it gives you the
strategy of what you could be doing so
how do you go from where you are now to
where you want to be well if you're
modeling success and you see what they
did it gives you hope plus the strategy
to actually go off and execute so coming
back to the theme of failure what this
video is all about you're gonna have
tons of failure it's gonna happen like
if you are not failing it means you're
not taking a big enough shot right if
you're not failing you're just doing
things that you know how to do
therefore you're just in your comfort
zone therefore you just hate your life
right if you're not if you have zero
failure happening in your life then
you're taking zero chances and you're
just doing what you know how to do and
you'll be bored and you won't like your
life so recognize that failure is a part
of the process and as soon as we can
move from past I suck as a human I made
all these mistakes too okay I'm moving
forward we're making progress we got a
big thing that we're chasing down when
you can move from failure to progress it
gives you the momentum it gives you the
hope it gives you the energy and ends up
giving you a lot better results as well
rule number nine set yourself up to when
some businesses are just easier to build
on the scale than others some businesses
have a high growth market and some of
them are slow growth it doesn't mean
that you can't win but the opportunity
is going to be much different the upside
is going to be much different depending
on the market that you're going into
I love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the world as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're gonna quit
you're gonna hate your life because
you're waking up every day and doing
work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle they do one of
those two things they try to start a
business just around their hobby what
they're passionate about but there's no
Market opportunity they don't know how
to tie it into real demand so they never
build a business just a hobby on the
weekends any events or
they're just chasing the hot opportunity
and they don't care about the business
and so either way you're going to lose
in both those scenarios you win by doing
the work that you love
that has a big opportunity upside to you
as well I want to share two quick
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was a dear
friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore Instagram
want to know what I was doing on
Instagram and I said you know what right
now I'm not doing much on Instagram
you know I'm not spending a lot of my
effort my time my energy on Instagram I
love serving I love helping I love
getting the message out there I want to
do it in a way that has the biggest
potential for impact and reach in the
projects I'm working on so he said well
where are you spending your effort and
energy well YouTube was still number one
YouTube is number one because YouTube is
still the best place to get your message
across
it has been for the past couple years
and it's only getting bigger more people
are going to YouTube for content for
Education it's only getting bigger so
YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord
Discord I think is the best place to be
for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby so I'm
spending a lot of my time on Twitter and
Discord and of course YouTube
and why well because that's where people
are that's where the impact is that's
where you get your message out and so I
don't care about the platform I care
about reaching people so you could spend
all day long working on on Instagram or
you could have spent all day long still
if you were working on MySpace creating
your account does Myspace still exist I
don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
example was I'm talking to a successful
entrepreneur who wants to move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground that is having a
hard time monetizing it
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing you can do right now if
you want to monetize it is coach people
who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming out doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believing themselves
helping them overcome the living beliefs
you know helping them
fixed our mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information in the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Bo and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had he was a stock boy at a
grocery store and you know he's mid six
figures Revenue 18 months later why well
because yes I'm giving him the belief in
the mindset and the motivation but I can
also give him contacts I can also make
introductions for him I can also give
him information about the industry to
know
what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking to
make an investment into an entrepreneur
I want to be able to help them Beyond
just believe because I can get believed
to anybody but whoever I want to give
believe to have the highest impact for
Success it's going to be people who I
can give contacts to Jeremy does YouTube
Consulting there's people who contact me
all the time for you to Consulting I
don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
not it's kind of blurry
um if you're an arborist I could help
you believe in yourself I can give you
some business model ideas but I can't
make contacts or introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
it has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
are you getting lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result what do you get lost in
the process of doing what industry do
you actually care about where are you
spending your time where are you
researching what doesn't feel like work
for you right so that's Step One is is
connecting to something that you're
actually passionate about not just
trying to make money right make money is
important but it's not step number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're going to pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour or just
helping people with mindset and not
actually introductions and tactics right
so you love the opportunity
it makes you come alive thinking about
it and
there's actually something for you to
grow
right logically strategically is a way
for you to make money doing it when you
can combine those two things you have a
much much much much much much higher
degree of success rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
Clips live with your purpose I'm going
to substitute mission for purpose your
purpose is what you are here for your
purposes what do you wake up excited to
do your purpose is what's the impact
that you want to have on the world what
do you want to be known for what do you
want to create
your purpose is the thing that keeps you
going when when you want to quit when
you want to give up when you feel like
it's not happening fast enough when your
goals aren't enough to keep you going
what is the thing that keeps you going
it's your purpose
to feel like what you are doing today
matters is Meaningful is going to have
an impact and
people have asked me somebody asked me
yesterday I was doing IG live and
somebody asked me how do you how do you
keep going you're one of the most
consistent people I've ever seen in my
life
uh how do you keep going how do you keep
making videos well I feel like it
matters I'm living my purpose I don't
think what I'm doing is that unique that
special I think everybody can do it
it's it's within reach for everybody to
do it the problem is most people are
just chasing opportunity
and just trying to make a quick buck and
making money is very important it is
very important it's just not number one
number one is your purpose
if you woke up and felt like today
mattered that it was gonna mean
something to somebody you're gonna show
up in a totally different way you're
going to show up with more energy it's
going to be easier to say yes
I was making videos for years with
getting almost no views zero comments
why because I felt like what I was doing
mattered that if a hundred people saw my
video that's 100 people that's on my
video or if you're just chasing the end
goal if you're just chasing oh I need to
have a million subscribers so I need to
have X in my bank account
you stop you will quit because it gets
too hard
where if you actually felt like I'm
gonna show up today and I'm gonna do
something that matters and it's going to
change at least one person's life there
are some days when you feel like you can
change the world right there are some
days when you feel like I can do
anything I could change the world I'm
going to X right there are some days
when you actually feel that and it's
amazing and there are some days where
that feels too big and too scary and
your purpose feels too overwhelming and
and it should be it should be
aspirational it should be beyond your
reach it should not be something that
just gets solved in your lifetime it's
something that you want to swim forever
to climb forever to keep chasing down so
there are some days where it feels too
big and on those days don't stress about
it being too big worry about hey I'm
just gonna help one person for me when
I'm stressing out about making content
making videos
speaking on stage whatever else I'm
doing some days like I'm gonna change
the world today and other days is
I hope I can reach a few people with the
video
this is a Tuesday for me I record videos
on Tuesday every Tuesday I make content
into my calendar and it's always the
most
stressful day for me
in my week because I always want to make
the best that I can I want I want
today's video to be the best that I can
with what I've got
because I want to have an impact I want
I want hopefully this video and the way
that I say it and just hope that this is
the one that finally resonates with at
least one person The Hope isn't I need
this video to go get a million views or
I'm a failure the hope is
that for you maybe for you maybe you're
the one today
that the way that I say it hits you in
the right spot that pushes you towards
some kind of action to take that thing
that's been sitting inside your heart
that you've been sitting on for a long
time that you know you'll want to do and
get the permission get the courage to
actually go off and do the thing
that's what purpose does for you
purpose demands that you grow into a
better version of yourself because you
won't do it just for yourself
if your goals are just purely selfish if
it's just to have money in your bank
account or buy a certain car or whatever
the goals just for yourself will not
sustain you through the long stretches
of bad times that it takes to go off and
actually build something meaningful the
thing that sustains you is feeling like
this is of Greater
service to other people than just me
Okay so
everybody has a purpose the purpose is
the thing that gets you going the
purpose is the thing that keeps you
motivated the person the purpose is the
thing that makes you want to do
something today how do you find it Well
finding it doesn't have to be a
difficult process I wrote about it in
built to serve I believe humans are
built to serve and finding your purpose
comes from your I call it your why and
your y comes in your pain your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
it's not something that changes next
year or the year after or the year after
it's not it's not what's my purpose for
this year
that's a decent enough conversation even
figuring that out if you wanted to go
down that path what's my purpose for the
year it's already more self-awareness
than what 99 of the world has but that's
still not your life's purpose your
purpose is the thing that at 120 years
old you're still obsessed about my
purpose isn't to grow my YouTube channel
I don't know if I'll be doing YouTube at
120 years old that's too far away for me
to think about my purpose is to try to
solve the world's biggest problem which
is that people don't believe in
themselves enough and when I'm 120 years
old that will still be there and I will
still be doing whatever the the modern
technology is right if it's YouTube
amazing if it's VR something totally
different I'll be doing that because I
want to solve that problem
that's what I wake up everybody trying
to do why well because the purpose comes
from my pain because what I struggle the
most with
me oh Nina brought some coffee we love
you Nina
look at the steam look at the steam I
bought this guy coffee and you bought
the homeless guy coffee he said it's his
birthday it's his birthday look at Nina
so special
spreading her purpose love it my purpose
came from my pain I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur
I felt the lowest
as a human I felt worthless I quit on my
business partner I thought it was never
going to work out I I just felt
incredible pain I felt lonely isolated
worthless
and I did quit on my business partner
and then luckily I came back the next
day and just decided I can't quit on
this yet and I'm still making all of
this content all of my material how many
years later let's see that was that was
when I was 19 20. I'm 41 now so 20 plus
years later still helping still making
content still going and it's going to be
another 80 years of doing this because
there are so many people millions of
people who are 19 year old Evan right
now struggling with the same thing
whatever you struggled with
think about in your life that the
deepest
most traumatic experience where you felt
worthless as a human being the most
painful emotionally moment that you had
to go through
and you barely made it you know you
didn't you didn't Triumph your way
through it you struggled but you made it
and now you're here and you're still not
where you want to be but you're way
further ahead than you used to be right
you right now could go back to you from
10 years ago five years ago seven years
ago and give some great advice
that's your purpose
to know that there are millions of
people right now who are currently the
person you used to be and they may not
make it through
they may not make it through like you
did you had the strength you had the
courage you had the strategies you found
the way and you made it through and they
may not and they need you they need your
voice they need your hope they need your
inspiration they need your message they
need you in a way that they won't listen
to me they won't listen to Tom bilyu or
Tony Robbins they won't listen because
they don't connect to us but they will
connect to you
because you are like them
so it doesn't have to take you years to
figure out your purpose you don't have
to go to a retreat you don't have to go
meditate on a mountain you don't have to
hire a fancy business coach you don't
you have to you don't have to do any of
that you already know it
you go back to the most painful moment
in your life
where you felt worthless as a human
being
and then just deeply connect to that and
feel and know that there are many people
out there right now who are that right
now
and they have no hope and no guidance
and no leadership and no wisdom and they
feel stuck and they they feel alone they
feel afraid they feel ashamed they're
not reaching out they're not asking for
help and they're going and they're
searching they're searching they're
going to YouTube they're going to
YouTube they're going to YouTube they're
going to YouTube how many times do I say
that they're going to Google they're
going to Twitter they're going to
Facebook they're they're searching
they're searching for help for answers
you could be the one that shows up
and if you actually felt that
[Music]
that on some days you could change the
world and on some days
you change one person's life if you
actually felt that
you will show up completely differently
finding your purpose and living it is
the thing that gives you the motivation
the strength the confidence
to show up one more day and keep going
the number one thing you can do for your
confidence is to do scary things when
you come up against something that's
scary that's difficult that's hard and
you don't do them you're telling
yourself that you can't and that you
suck you're teaching yourself with every
inaction that you're the kind of person
who plays small you need to flip that
thinking it's scary you do it it's scary
you're jumping because you do scary
things you want to be scared if you have
things that make you scared it means
you're growing you're learning you're
getting better if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared in
the next month you hate your life
that's actually most people most people
don't have everything in their calendar
that is scary and they look at their
calendar head and they hate their life
they're bored they're photocopying the
same day over and over again you don't
want that so the goal isn't to not be
scared because that means you're playing
small the goal is to find things that
are scary and that to teach yourself
that you do them we often get inspired
whether it's watching a video like this
doing you know hearing an interview from
Michael or somebody else reading a book
how many times you've read a book and
been inspired but then you don't do
anything and we say okay tomorrow we're
going to do it and the next week we're
going to do it and then nothing ends up
happening
so if you got inspired by this you took
any idea from this
the best thing you can do is today take
one small piece of action towards it if
your goal is I want to be a YouTuber as
well great the best thing you can do is
make a video
if your goal is to write your own book
great the best thing you do right now is
write the first page of content
and expect it to suck
just expect it to suck your first page
is gonna suck your first video is
definitely gonna suck it doesn't mean
you suck as a human it just means you
don't have the skill set yet why would
you have the skill set if it's your
first time doing it
so just
expect to suck but get started because
that's the thing that most people Miss
there's a lot of smart people who
consume a lot of content who can who can
say what I'm gonna say before I say it
because they've seen so much of it and
I've read so many books thousands of
books and had them memorized but then
they're still stuck in life
because you're not taking the action
so the most important thing you can do
when you're reading a book at least I
think when you're reading the book when
you're watching a video go pause it put
the book down for a second pause the
video and then go take some immediate
action from it if you look at all those
books on Michael's shelf behind you if
you all have that collection and in each
one of those books you actually took
just one idea away from it and did
something about it your life will be
dramatically different
so the message is do something today do
something today to get some momentum on
your big goal I feel like what I do
matters
and I think I think that's really really
important I think people are starting
the business only trying to make money
often burn out and and don't make money
I've been doing YouTube for 12 years now
we've done over 10 000 videos not all of
them are public and people ask me well
how do you keep going like how do you
not burn out how do you stay consistent
we haven't missed a day of uploading
video in maybe 70 years something like
that something crazy
uh well how because
I love what I'm doing because I feel
like it matters because this isn't it
look at this interview here with Michael
is this work this doesn't feel like work
for me this is fun
this is a holiday in Canada for me right
now this is our Independence Day right
now we're filming this on Canada
Independence Day right now and I'm here
talking with Michael because it's fun
right and so when you're doing work that
you love and you feel is having an
impact it's a lot easier to stay
positive and excited and have momentum
where if you're forcing yourself to do
something that you hate because you
think it's going to make you money
that's when you start diving on the path
of boredom
um and maybe ultimately depression what
I love doing is I want to teach myself I
want to inoculate myself against
judgment
I want to teach myself that if if my
heart's beaten boom boom boom boom boom
it's a sign that I need to go do the
thing
most of the things that we're afraid of
doing
are because of other people's opinions
right yeah you're playing small because
you're worried how somebody's going to
judge you you'll sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner you
record a video but you won't post it on
YouTube yeah right you want to do great
things but you're afraid of the reaction
that's going to happen so
so that if you can if you can feel that
then it's man I don't want to live my
whole life plain small because of
somebody else's opinion on me now we got
entrepreneurs who are watching
entrepreneurs we want to do different
things we want to we want to change the
status quo there's a lot of people who
want to protect the status quo all those
people who want to protect the status
quo they won't like you by default just
because of what you represent without
knowing you
they just don't like what you represent
so they're going to hate on you yeah you
represent the idea of what they could be
doing possibly if they were willing to
put themselves out there sure you're
taking stuff away from them you know
they they don't like that so they hate
you just by definition right so if you
want to go off and have a huge impact
you're going to get the bigger impact
you want the more people are going to
line up against you who want to protect
what currently is yeah and so if you
can't do something as simple as
ask a girl out or sing on the street or
something simple then you're never going
to do the big thing I did everything
myself at the beginning I had I was
doing one video per week on YouTube and
then the first hire I had was an editor
and that let me go to one video a day
instead of just one video a week and so
the sooner you can start to incorporate
people in your life who can support you
either emotional support you know Nina
my wife now is involved in my business
is my chief heart officer and does a lot
of work inside the company but at the
beginning she she didn't know anything
about YouTube besides watching she
didn't give me any advice she really
know what to do but just supporting me
just encouraging me just understanding
me that that's a big it makes a big
difference when you have somebody in
your life who's just there for you and
understands you even if they can't give
you practical knowledge just that
support is helpful but then also the
people who can actually do the thing
that you need help with even if it's for
one hour a week or one hour a day like
that first person I hired was one hour a
day and that saved one a half to two
hours a day of my time because he was
better at the thing than I was so you
don't need to have a big budget to go
hire somebody but if you have a big
mission then you have to realize that
ultimately you can't do this alone and
make a commitment that by the end of
next month you're going to have somebody
else on your team helping you I think
99.99 of people are built to serve I
think I think we get we get Happiness by
helping other people with what we can
help them with I think there's a tiny
tiny percentage of people who who enjoy
killing people the gut brain chemicals
kind of messed up but most people aren't
like that right thankfully we wouldn't
be here in general we want to
they involve somebody else think I think
your happiest most proud moments of all
time they involve somebody else you've
helped
the the the the winning for you the
Great Moments won't just be receiving
some check or making a lot of money it's
like how are you going to use that to
help somebody else so we're wired to
serve just not everybody's wired to
serve the world so you have to
understand your style for people
watching this show they're probably
where to serve the world entrepreneurs
we want to make a big impact a big
change a big difference yeah but not
everybody is built that way some people
just they want to serve the closest
people friends family you know my wife
is still in touch with people from her
grade one in China you know like she
keeps in touch with people like
she's a master networker I guess too but
I don't um I don't I don't care that
much about
about people like that I want to help
the world there was a really interesting
question that somebody asked me uh like
would you rather would I rather have a
hundred thousand people really
understand my message and get it
or or my son
and I picked a hundred thousand people
wow
and my wife
and wasn't happy right now I don't know
what no no she was not happy she gets it
but but it but it's just a different
approach now where does the I don't know
how what's the number is it is it one
thousand is it five thousand I don't
want to go down that slippery but that
idea of you know ultimately if my wife
really needed something
from me I would be there for her but but
at the end of the day I need to be free
to be doing the work that I love doing
yeah and so you you have to find a way
to serve I was in New Mexico
and I was doing uh on Super Bowl Sunday
my workshop and it was the smallest
group on our tour and we're talking
about morning routines and there was a
woman there and I asked her what what's
the most important part of your morning
routine and she said prayer I said so
you pray how often do you pray every day
every day every day praise your praise
perfect how often do you feel
the prayer how often do you feel the
connection and how often are you just
saying the words
you said like half the time
great
other people might look to her and say
well look you do it every day even for
herself she might look in herself and
say great I did it every day as
Achievers we'd like to check the box
right you like to check the box I did it
I did it I did it I did it I did it I
prayed I watched the video I read the
book I brushed my teeth I whatever you
have your checklist and you did it right
and you feel great that you did it but
if you don't get the feeling
of courageousness and you just check the
box it doesn't count
so watching a video might be part of
your morning routine
great I'm you know if it's mine I'm
honored to be a part of your journey but
somebody else is amazing do that too
but if you know that watching the video
is the thing that helps make you feel
alive bold confident
you know that there are some days that
watching a video actually makes you feel
that way and other days where it doesn't
and you know that watching the same
video over and over and over and over
every day will lose its impact super
quick right day one you're motivated day
two already you've lost like 80 of the
motivation that you got from day one day
three it's basically over you run it for
a month forget it like you've already
memorized the words that the words don't
mean anything to you anymore
so you have to have some variety
and if you're watching a video while
you're doing something else
this is the achiever's curse you're
watching the video while you're brushing
your teeth while you're taking the dogs
out while you're cleaning the sink while
you're making the bed you're distracted
you're doing something else you're
trying to multitask right here's what
happened to the achievers you still get
to check the box to say that you watch
the video
but because you weren't present for the
video guess what happens there was no
retention there was no feeling you don't
feel ready to take on the day you don't
feel the boldness to courageousness and
therefore you don't go and have a great
day even though you checked off
everything on your morning routine
that's what makes a difference
so if you get to the end of your morning
routine and you don't feel bold powerful
courageous ready to go for the day
there's one of two things that you have
to do one is you audit your morning
routine you say What's missing
you know like does this still work for
you anymore what's missing do I need to
add something in do I need to add an
espresso video in during the morning do
I need to add reading do I need to add
working out do I need to add writing my
goals now like what do you need to do to
add and tweak and experiment and see if
it makes you feel better or two
maybe you just need to do the routine
again but with more intention maybe you
did the whole routine while you were
distracted
maybe you did the whole routine while
you're thinking something else
so you don't get the feeling there's
nothing wrong with the routine the
routine is great
routine is perfect for you
but if you don't show up with intention
if you don't show up and be focused on
it you're not going to get the feeling
you could sit there and be in the chair
and think about going to classes going
to school you could sit there be in the
chair doesn't mean that you're going to
learn
you can sit there and watch your video
but if you brush your teeth and doing
eight other things
you're not going to get the feeling
this is the loving push forward that I
hope you accept
because everybody else is going to look
at you and see how much you're doing and
how perfect you are and how much
momentum you have and how many things
you're doing and they look up to you in
awe
and you're an inspiration to them and
you should be because you are doing
amazing things
and at the same time you know it's
nothing compared to what you could do
but the difference between where you are
right now where you want to go is
actually not that big
the difference is just minor tweaks
between where you are right now where
you want to go for most of you it's just
minor tweaks
this is one of those minor tweaks
that if you could just stay consistent
on having a morning routine
and then inside of that consistency
doing the thing that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable alive ready to
start the day not expecting to be
amazing when you wake up but then doing
the thing that brings that out of you
every single day your life
will change immediate action
immediate action to start building some
kind of momentum this is the problem
this is what we're missing what's the
first step that most of us take what's
the first step that you take what's the
first step
you most often immediately start to talk
yourself down does this does this relate
does this connect like as soon as you
get the idea immediately you're talking
yourself down forget about telling
friends family that that's a problem no
it's it's you it's your own mind that's
holding you back saying you can't do
things
after that what do we do we go into
planning mode plan plan plan plan plan
plan gonna research gonna make my
perfect plan gonna gonna write out all
my questions for this interview gonna
you know research research research and
then and then what and then what happens
nothing
because you spend the first day planning
and you wake up tomorrow and you tell
yourself that you can't do it
[Music]
so the first step is not planning
planning is important but it's not the
first step the first step is some kind
of immediate action this is where people
get cut UPS like what's the perfect
first step there is no perfect person
guys there's no pressure
anything you want to write a book
take out a your notepad your typewriter
who uses a typewriter your laptop your
computer whatever
and just start writing take out take out
a piece of paper like this and just
start writing like if you're stuck in
the car and you come with a great idea
for what you should be doing for your
book pull over or if somebody else is
driving Nina drives while I while I film
his videos take out a piece of paper and
just start writing on this you'll be
thinking but this is nothing and you're
right but you know what something the
first step
momentum because your scribble notes
down here
that means everything
that's more progress than most people
ever make on their goals
because once you get started the next
step becomes so much easier it's the
first step that sucks the first step
that seems so giant
so don't worry about the perfect first
step just start building some immediate
momentum learn to take crappy first
steps
crappy first steps
crappy First Steps this is where
intentional learning really makes a
difference
I can't tell you the number of events
that I've done
whether it's virtual or in person where
there's always q a at some point
so if you're going to an event or you're
signing up for for a zoom call and the
person who you want to learn from is on
that call what most people do is they
become passive listeners
you're passively taking out your notepad
and you're taking notes you got your
phone and you're like taking notes on it
and like oh that's a good Insight that's
a good Insight but it's passive because
you are not
going in to the event with an outcome
your goal should be if you want to make
learning active if you want to actually
get the most from the experience and be
able to make the contacts and get your
questions answered you have to know what
the question is going to be
that you're gonna ask right so here's
what you should do
first off whoever Your Heroes mentors
guides are
you want to follow them on all the
platforms so they can go live I just
before this I was live on Instagram
and we had a whole bunch of people
asking questions
follow if you want to talk to me follow
me on Instagram
join my Discord Evan carmichael.biz get
in there we're having great
conversations but the people who are
your Heroes follow them on the platforms
where they might go live look at where
they might be speaking at an upcoming
event
and then when you go and attend that
event have a plan for your learning so
that it's not just passively going
through the exercise and activities that
they gave you that's all a bonus
if you're going to go to some conference
and there's an activity sheet or
workbook to go through great that's all
a bonus you need to know going in
what do I want to learn if I got a
chance to ask this person one question
what would that question be
what's the outcome that I want from this
most people don't do that
and you get caught up in the hype and
the energy and the motivation of ah it's
so amazing
but then you still didn't get the answer
that you could have had if you're just
more intentional
so you show up and then when they do the
questions like okay we're going to q a
boom you're the first one there
you're the first one there you're not
you're not you might be nervous your
heart might be pounding out of your
chest like crazy but you're the first
one there you're standing by the
microphone you're ready to go you got
your hand up before they even go to q a
in the zoom chat right like you are
ready to go with your question the one
that you want and answer to
and then you're gonna ask the person hey
here's what I'm struggling with here's
what I'm working on
tell me why I suck
and then you get the feedback
if you apply that strategy
and go after the top five to ten people
in your industry in your Niche who are
doing the thing you can get access to
them
and if you intentionally show up with
that one question that you want an
answer to
and then you end it with tell me why I
suck
you'll get their brutal honest feedback
and get the advice you actually need to
grow apply the two percent difference
the two percent difference means as soon
as you get a goal in mind most things
that we want to do most people what we
what we do is we think of planning
that's step number one for most people
it's planning no don't plan your first
step after you come with an idea is to
act planning is important it's just not
your first step most people will plan
their way to 100 right plan to how I'm
going to accomplish my goal and then
they wake up tomorrow they've lost the
boldness they lost the confidence and
they say I'm not going to do that I
can't do that and there's no momentum
and then the dream dies on the table the
first step is momentum the first step is
action the first step is figuring out
the first two percent that's it two
percent don't plan to 100 instead act on
the first two percent why is it so
important because when you're feeling
bold when you're feeling confident when
you get that idea it's flowing through
you right you're in that energy Zone you
want to use that energy to build
momentum using that best energy to go
into planning and then you wake up
tomorrow a different person you've lost
it all where if you use that energy into
action into momentum then tomorrow
you're gonna wake up and see oh I've
already built some momentum it's easier
to keep the ball rolling the hardest
step is the first one so push build that
first step when you're feeling the
energy so as soon as you get your next
idea apply the two percent difference
your first step is to act great ideas
flow through you teach yourself train
yourself that great ideas are flowing
through you that the idea that you just
came up with that you've been thinking
of that doesn't make any sense is great
is amazing and is right for you because
quite often the ideas that come to you
don't make sense
are not practical someone like you
shouldn't do it
and whenever your head in your heart are
misaligned
whenever your heart wants to do
something but your head tells you that
you can't do it
if you listen to your head you'll stay
small if you listen to the Practical
reasons why you can't do it then guess
what you won't do it you'll stay stuck
you'll stay small you'll stay crushed
for life knowing that you're capable of
more but never going after it so trust
that great things flow through you trust
that this thing that just came into your
mind if you're feeling bold ambitious
confidence in service that it's the
right thing for you and you need to go
and Chase it down the biggest mistake so
many entrepreneurs make is they jump
into a business because they see that
it's a hot opportunity you don't love it
you don't know much about it but so many
people are talking about it and it looks
like an easy way to make a lot of money
big mistake don't do that it's the
fastest way to go broke so Warren
Buffett did not invest in Amazon but
he's still done pretty well for himself
he didn't invest in Amazon because he
doesn't like Tech he doesn't know it he
doesn't love it he doesn't live in that
space and so he doesn't want to buy
those kinds of companies and great human
missed out on Amazon but he also missed
out on all the tech companies that
didn't make it that he could have put
money into that just would have gone to
zero he knows what he's great at he
knows what he loves and he sticks in his
Arena I'll look at what I'm doing
there's so many opportunities that come
my way that I know nothing about I have
no interest in I don't want to have
interest in that I'm I'm losing money on
right I don't like real estate I hate
real estate I don't wanna I don't want
to be in it I don't want to learn about
it I don't like real estate it's not
that it's not a good opportunity it's
just not for me it's boring to me I have
zero interest in real estate it's great
for so many people so many people have
built amazing wealth and generational
wealth based off of real estate amazing
I'm pumped for you it's just not the
thing that I want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when Bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert I know nothing
about cryptocurrency I bought zero
cryptocurrency in my life I've been
given zero cryptocurrency in my life is
cryptocurrency the future yep when is it
gonna come I don't know is it gonna be
Bitcoin I don't know I I don't know
anything about cryptocurrency I get the
mechanics and the general theory and I
know that it's coming but it's not the
opportunity for me
CBD is a big thing now right everybody's
getting into CBD and CBD oils and CBD
products and great and it's becoming
legal here in Canada or it already is
legal in a bunch of our provinces and
it's going to be legalized across many
states if not the whole country
awesome it's not me I don't I don't I'm
not into CBD I don't I don't smoke any
marijuana I never have I'm not
interested in it it may help you it may
alleviate your pain amazingness may be
the greatest gift you've ever seen in
your life amazing but if you're only
jumping into it because you think it's a
hot opportunity you're gonna
that being said I'm also involved in so
many things that are hot opportunities
I'm drowning in Opportunities I have too
many opportunities that I know what to
do with let alone don't know what to do
with looking at YouTube YouTube right
now is still a massive opportunity
there's so many people who look at what
I've done who look at what Gary have
done and Grant Cardone and those guys
have done they say I want to do it
YouTube is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader if
you want to have educational content
YouTube is still a huge opportunity most
people who are the experts at what they
do are not on YouTube that means you can
go on even with a little bit less
expertise and go and crush it because
the people who are the best in the world
are doing it they're not doing it it's a
huge opportunity it's a big white space
still right now even though I've been on
it for 10 years YouTube has evolved a
lot over the past decade and there's
still tons of white space open and
available I need to push the opportunity
harder have a good thought leadership is
another one thought leadership the stuff
that I'm doing the videos like this the
teaching that I've done the workshops
that I've done people want to be a
thought leader not just an influencer
but a thought leader and I'm at the
center of that Trend I'm helping train a
lot of hot lingers people are coming to
me asking me for help in becoming a
thought leader and making content and
being able to do good videos and be able
to get speaking gigs book deals all of
it people want it it's happening and I'm
at the center of that Trend too League
of Legends I love League of Legends I've
been playing League of Legends for this
is six years this is my six year playing
League of Legends I play Teemo look I
got I got I got Teemo here I got Teemo
here I got Tristana here I've named my
dogs Timo and Tristana right I play
three games a night on my twitch stream
you can come to my twitch stream
twitch.tv slash believeteam come join me
I play there three games a night I'm
trying to get the gold uh this season
which means I'm in the top 10 of players
uh in North America so that's my it's my
ambition for the year I watch League of
Legends every weekend I have a TSM
Jersey let me get it
I have a TSM Jersey I'm a fan I love
League of Legends I love Esports if you
are getting to Esports just because it's
a hot opportunity and you don't love it
you're gonna die You're Gonna Lose I
look at garyvee as an example and Gary's
done an amazing job in hip-hop an
amazing job in hip-hop and he's brought
so many different artists on from the
top of nipsy hustle all the way down to
people who are just breaking in and
trying to get their start he loves
hip-hop he loves the lyrics he loves the
culture and so he's really built a name
for himself inside of hip-hop he got
into twitch a little bit he had a twitch
Studio set up in his office and he
started doing a little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades and so it's not authentic for
him and so he's not gonna win there I
love Esports I love League of Legends I
love gaming it's part of what I do I can
talk to you about the current roster for
TSM and my thoughts on it I could talk
about the new patch that came out on
League of Legends and how Timo is doing
I like it it's just I genuinely like it
and so I have these opportunities in
front of me already within YouTube
within thought leadership within Esports
that that I can take advantage of and
blow up in and I don't need to worry
about real estate and cryptocurrency and
CBD and all the other millions of
opportunities out there there's already
tons of opportunities inside the things
that you already know and love the
things that you know and love there's
lots of people who know and love that
thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers you
could be the person who gives them the
answers
jumping on some train because you think
it's a hot opportunity and a chance to
make money is the fastest way that you
will lose money because you don't
understand anything about that if you
don't love Esports don't go spend money
on an Esports team
is a tremendous opportunity and that's
what you need to focus on most people
suck at creating work-life balance or
Harmony because you're constantly
comparing what you're doing to other
people's schedules of all the things
that you need to figure out in life what
balance means to you is among the most
important Jeff Bezos jokes about
optimizing his toothbrushing routine
because he's trying to maximize his
efficiency while Warren Buffett reads
for five to six hours every day you
can't do both and you need to stop
comparing yourself to someone who you're
not it's crazy how much balance and
scheduling comes up I think most people
are lost I think I think again the
biggest problem is you're just comparing
yourself to other people and then you
don't know where to stand you don't know
what rock to stand on and so you feel
like you're pulled in a thousand
different directions when I went on my
tour this year and I'm sure it's going
to come up on the next one again people
kept asking that what does balance mean
to you how do I find balance in my life
and I used to joke one of the funniest
jokes that I told and I'm not that funny
so this is this is one of the funny
moments
um was when I was talking about the Rock
and The Rock has his routine where he's
working out for four hours a day he has
to work out for four hours a day and so
when he's doing his movies he wakes up
five hours before he has to be on set
and he'll work out for his four hours
and he'll do two times cardio and two
times weights and then go to the you
know go to his trailer shower and then
head head out to the movies and he's
only sleeping four to five hours a night
when he's on set
I think that's crazy but I don't look
like the Rock and that's when people
would laugh because I don't look like
the rock but it's true people will try
to take on the Rock schedule but you
have other priorities
what the Rock values isn't the same
thing as you value there may be some
overlap and some similarities and
there's nothing wrong with trying on the
hat there's nothing wrong with
attempting to do it there's nothing
wrong with seeing how it fits right to
get pieces to say hey I'm gonna try
meditating I'm going to try working out
I'm gonna try making a video I'm gonna
try morning Pages I'm gonna awesome
great yes
but then to judge yourself to say well
I'm not able to stay consistent on that
it's not what you should be doing
because you want to work out four hours
a day and you want to read five hours a
day like Warren Buffett and you want to
optimize your toothbrush routine like
Jeff Bezos and you want to do all these
different things but it's too many hours
in a day what you have to figure out is
how does balance look like for you and
then not be ashamed to go off and live
it when everybody else thinks you're
nuts doing what you are afraid of is
your path to success every time you take
on something new that scares you that
pushes your comfort zone that requires
you to stretch on the other side of that
scary thing is the new you who is now
capable of more most people they shrink
from scary things
because they're scary but if you want to
win if you want to hit your ambitious
goals then you have to teach yourself
that you do scary things so I recently
came back from two pretty significant
speaking gigs uh in my career as I'm as
I'm building up and speaking on bigger
stages the first was when I was speaking
of Brendan burchard's event and it's his
growth.com event and Brendan one of the
greatest speakers in the world invited
me to come and talk to his group of
couple thousand people and then I went
to Ed mylett's event just recently in
Whistler and this is a smaller group 100
so people but they pay sixty thousand
dollars a year to be a part of his
program and so they're coming to learn
from the best he sandwiched me between
David Goggins and Peyton Manning so it's
David Goggins and then me and then
Peyton Manning that was the lineup and
so
when I was backstage at the Brendan
event
I remember moments before going on stage
I was the most scared that I'd been in a
long time the most nervous and most
anxious I was afraid of disappointing
people my biggest fear is letting people
down my biggest fear is that I'm gonna
let Brendan down and Dean grazios who
they both brought me there and I was
just gonna suck on stage that was my
biggest fear and so I had a mini panic
attack backstage five minutes before
going up I have this mini panic attack
and I'm forgetting what I'm gonna say I
I imagine myself going on stage and just
blanking out
and I tell myself I'm Evan Carmichael I
do difficult things I love difficult
things if I don't do difficult things
I'm never going to accomplish great
things so I have to do difficult things
I love it I thrive on difficult things
and then I remembered what I was gonna
say and then I went out and I did my
thing
and now when I went to Ed's event
I wasn't as nervous I wasn't as afraid I
was still scared I was still afraid of
letting down at my left letting down
Andy Priscilla who they both brought me
there
being between David Goggins and Peyton
Manning and just being out Shawn uh you
know everybody knows them they may not
know me all of it all of the fears and
doubts but less than what I had at
Brendan's event not because it wasn't as
big a deal but because I had just done
it because speaking on Sage a couple
thousand people at Brendan's event and
having that panic attack and getting
through it
changed who I was
Made Me Stronger made me more capable of
doing the next thing and the next thing
was Ed's thing and so if I hadn't gone
to Brandon's I would be terrified going
to Ed's thing
so every time you take on these
difficult challenges
you might have the panic attack you
might have the anxiety inside you you
might have that little voice to say you
can't do it what if you fail what if you
disappoint people what if you lose
respect what if it doesn't work out
but you know what's worse you know
what's worse than going up and failing
not trying
not doing it
finding some reason finding some excuse
to say you're sick you're busy you can't
make it but in the back of your head
you know you're just afraid and the last
thing you want to do is teach yourself
that when you are afraid that when you
have an opportunity in front of you and
you're afraid to do it that you say no
you don't want to teach yourself that
you teach yourself the opposite that
when you're afraid that when there's
something in front of you that you want
to do but you're scared you're anxious
you're worried about letting people down
that you jump in
and you say I'm all in because I do
scary things most people never hit their
goals because they don't structure their
life towards actually accomplishing
those goals you can say that you want
something you can say that this is your
ambition and your goal but unless it's
in your calendar unless you start
actually working towards it you're never
going to accomplish it dreams Day Dreams
because there is no momentum let's talk
about how to get it one of the common
questions I get asked when I'm doing my
live stream when I'm doing my my
interviews when I'm doing my my tour my
stops people almost always will ask me
how many hours of sleep do you get when
you go to bed when you get up how much
do you sleep every night right now I'm
sleeping nine hours a day I sleep nine
hours I did a sleep study I was sleeping
around eight and getting and was still
tired when I woke up and so I went and
did an overnight sleep study and they
told me I'm looking for the hack I'm
like hey you're you're deficient in
magnesium so just take these and you can
sleep seven and be normal
he said no nothing wrong with you you
just need to sleep nine hours a night
that's healthy for you like what that's
healthy are you kidding me what are you
talking about nobody Sleeps nine hours a
night it's like yeah between six and ten
is actually that's the normal range the
whole eight hours a night is a myth so I
felt bad and I'm still trying to hack it
so I sleep nine hours a night I don't
wake up to an alarm
and people assume that I am I'm Only
Sleeping three four or five hours a
night because of how productive I am
during the day this is it right you
could sleep 12 hours a night and crush
it in the other 12 hours most people
default the thinking they needed to wake
up an hour really say well if I wake up
at 5am or at four a.m I'm gonna be more
productive if you are not productive for
16 hours a day then add in an extra hour
to that's not going to make you that
much more productive the problem isn't
what time you wake up the problem is
what you're doing with the hours that
you're awake and so as much as possible
what I try to do is make every second
intentional not always able to achieve
that especially not every second but but
I try to make everything intentional I
try to make every where I'm spending
time is intentional I'm in the present
I'm not thinking about something else
I'm here with you guys making this video
right now all I think about is this
video that I'm making for you right now
where is Nina right now I don't know
where's my cell phone well it's right
here because I can see it but where are
my keys I don't know where my dogs I
don't know what am I doing after this I
have no idea
I'm focused and I'm with you right now
most people live in the past most people
are thinking about what could have been
most people are regretting the decisions
that they made and they're
procrastinating because they're afraid
of doing things because they don't want
to do things
all things that prevent you from
actually doing
that's the biggest problem you're a
genius you're the best in the world at
something you can go off and make
amazing things the problem is your time
is not being used efficiently
it's not being used effectively either
you haven't structured your life
to help you accomplish your goals look
at your big goals look at your big goals
like what's the next big goal that you
have for yourself you may not have one
if that's that if you don't have one
then you got to figure out what your
purpose is because that's the greatest
thing of all time right get the book
build the serve you'll figure it out
you'll be you'll be ignited
but your next big goal now look at your
calendar are you aligning
what's in your calendar your daily
habits towards you accomplishing your
goals and for most people it's it's no
or you're you have it listed but you're
not doing it because you look at it and
you get afraid and you procrastinate on
it
so trying to cut that down to almost
zero even before making these videos
before making expressive videos I have
a couple minutes of procrastination
um I go and make sure I get my water I
go and maybe have a keto bar just pacing
around a little bit because I'm nervous
about making the videos because I want
them to be the best videos that I've
ever made it's always my intention
but too many people live in hours or
days or months of procrastination
instead of doing it you get the results
by doing it's the only way you will
never get the results by just thinking
about it you can be motivated amazing
you have the mindset awesome that's half
the equation the other half is doing you
have to actually just go out there and
do you need to structure your life
to allow you to accomplish your goals
people are afraid to tell the truth
you're
a Jew you're afraid they're going to
reject you you're afraid they're not
going to take it well you're afraid
they're going to be sensitive but you're
actually doing everybody a disservice
and you're going to walk away from the
conversation cheating like I could have
helped them I could have been more
valuable to them I could have saved them
for making a really bad decision a
really big mistake all because you were
afraid to tell the truth whenever I'm
meeting somebody I go to an event I just
came back for an event in Dallas video
marketing World whenever I'm meeting
somebody that I want to learn from I
will start off saying hey man tell me
why I suck tell me why I suck if I'm
looking at my YouTube thumbnails or my
titles or me on camera or any part of
something that I want to improve and
work on
tell me why I suck
now why why do that well it's not just
because I'm a glutton for punishment
right I don't want people just yelling
and raging at me it's because when you
do that when you lead with that when you
say tell me why I suck
it gives the other person the permission
to be honest with you
because they have advice that can help
you they have advice that might be able
to change your business or your life but
they're gonna hedge they're gonna play
it safe they're not going to tell you
what you need to hear because they're
afraid of offending you they're afraid
of hurting your feelings and so you open
up and you say tell me that I suck and
why
and then invariably what the answer is
is well you don't suck but you know you
could do this this and that
and they'll tell you what you need to
fix
or otherwise if you didn't lead with the
tell me why I suck they would hedge and
they wouldn't tell you everything that's
in their mind they wouldn't tell you the
thing that you need the most which is
their honest brutal opinion on what you
do now it doesn't mean that you suck as
a human
you're amazing as a human it just means
you don't have the skill set you're not
good at this one thing that this person
is an expert at and can help you
and so the next time you're going to an
event or you're talking to somebody who
might be able to help you lead with it
lead with and say I love I respect you I
love what you do I'm trying to work on
this tell me why I suck
and then watch the honesty come through
nobody wakes up every day and says this
is gonna be the greatest day ever not to
unlock not Evan Carmichael not Tony
Robbins no nobody you wake up and you're
tired and you have stuff in your eyes
and you have lines on your face from the
pillows the difference between
successful people is that they demand
Excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do daily the
problem is that thinking that these
people are different that if you're not
waking up with tons of motivation ready
to take on the day that something is
wrong with you the only thing that's
wrong with you is you don't have the
habits that set you up for Success every
single day and today I want to change
that so I have a 5S morning routine that
I go through every single day that sets
me up for Success that demands
Excellence I'm gonna share with you guys
today the first s is sing the fastest
way to change your state is to put on
music the fastest way to go from feeling
low energy tired bored into an energy of
I am ready to go is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're going to put on really
mellow slow music what does that do it
keeps you in the same state that you're
in
it keeps you exactly where you are what
you want to do is put on the music for
how you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody this is the
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're gonna
dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
gonna start building out the lyrics that
may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like to
dance something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on it's the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also signifying that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving the condo the apartment the home
you're leaving what happened last night
and you're ready to go off and start the
day this is especially important if
you're working from home because it's
easy to have your you know office right
next to your bedroom or maybe your
office is your bedroom
and carry that bedroom energy that tired
I just woke up I want to stay in bed I
want to sleep energy into your work and
you won't do great things if that's the
energy you're carrying to your work so
having some kind of ritual that splits
up sleeping energy to I'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and I find
the easiest way to do it is to get
outside and get some sun bonus points if
you're in a condo apartment to take the
stairs instead of the elevator s number
three is sore and this is the most
important thing for me if you only take
one of the five I think this is the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you soar every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt bold you felt
Unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently every
day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the I don't know if I can do it
I don't know who am I to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence plan it
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday
I think of somebody who commented on a
video who I met in person who I coached
on my Instagram live somebody that I
helped yesterday and then I make a
message channeling that person I won't
say the person's name but I have them in
my head I need to remind myself that the
work that I do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard
like what does it even mean I don't know
I'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy I need to think down
to the actual person I need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work I do really means
something to them and then I need to
record a message and share that helps me
soar and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the espresso videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be a part of your
morning routine for other people it
might be meditating they might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book listening to a podcast I don't care
what the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth s for
me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and I want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout I put that into my daily
routine because I want to bust a sweat
and I want to stay healthy into my 40s
which is coming up and then into my 50s
and Beyond and then the last s for me is
scare I want to do something every day
that scares me what I'm doing right now
is to take a cold shower so after
sweating I need to have a shower they
want to show up to work all smelly and
so hop in the shower but right away
start turning the colder and colder and
colder and colder and colder and then
right at the very end I go all the way
cold and I freeze and even just sticking
for right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way wrapped in the beginning I find
really helps me your actions have to map
to your Ambitions in a one-off situation
you can always be grateful for what
happened when I broke my neck in
Colorado I'm grateful for the
opportunity I'm the opportunity to learn
to push myself to get better but did it
map to my ambitions right whenever
you're stuck in a one-off situation you
can yes always default the Gratitude but
if you get the choice this is the
difference between living an intentional
versus a reactionary life
if you're just grateful for everything
that happens to you and see it as a
journey yes and you've learned yes great
but is it the journey that you want to
be on it's a journey that will get you
to where you want to go because if the
person who wants to hit the town ends up
on the farm
maybe he's not happy maybe that's not
his Ambitions now you might say that
actually served him that is something
that he should have gone down right
every road leads to somewhere but is it
the road that you want to go down do
your actions map to your Ambitions I
think it's really important the guy who
climbed the tree amaze
right his goal was to be there fastest
to take the shortest path that's the
path you should take and yes he was
right and the others are wrong he was
right for him because he wanted to take
the shortest path do your actions map to
your Ambitions you have goals look at
your calendar look at how you're
scheduling your time look at where
you're spending time what you're doing
it on will the actions that you're
taking lead you to accomplish the goals
that you're trying to go after
if yes amazing if not switch things up
I think too often people have hopes and
dreams and desires and Ambitions but
then their schedule doesn't match up you
say you want to do this but when I look
at your calendar it doesn't show me that
you're doing it if you want to have a
YouTube channel show me in your calendar
where you're making YouTube videos for
too many people it's never you're just
not doing it ever so then it just
becomes a hope a dream a wish a someday
some day is not a day of the week right
you got to put it in your calendar make
sure your action is mapped to your
Ambitions the problem isn't that you're
not a genius that you're not talented
that you don't have wisdom and abilities
and resourcefulness and that you're not
Michael Jordan that's not the problem
the problem is you're not focused you're
not doing the things that you need to do
I just came back from video marketing
World in Dallas and I was being asked
about where to spend your time Which
social media sites to spend time on and
I think this is a classic example of
where entrepreneurs fail is you're
trying to do everything and as a result
you suck everywhere and feel burnt out
tapped out and not building momentum if
you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did I get
done if that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and feel like what did I
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
I quoted Andrew Carnegie at my event at
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are one
person show with 18 streams of income
they're making no money you're making
ten dollars a month from this and 25 a
month from that and 18 cents from this
you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like I do I've got 24
people on my team okay great now it
might be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something and
that's what you need to find and that's
where you need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow people don't show
up for one of three reasons number one
is you're afraid you're afraid of
rejection you're afraid of failure
you're afraid of it not working out and
so you just don't show up number two is
you're not consistent you show up some
days but you don't show up other days
because you don't have the routines and
habits in place to make you show up
consistently every single day and number
three is you don't want to you don't
want to show up because you don't
actually enjoy the thing that you're
about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around so my goal
today with this video is to help you
bust through these so that you can show
up for life and have the impact that you
want to have so I think the fear of
showing up is actually a good thing it
means that you are doing something
different something outside your comfort
zone something that is that is not
normal that is new and that's good you
want to be pushing the envelope if there
was nothing that you are afraid to show
up to today tomorrow next week then
you're not growing you're not learning
you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up and and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel and more across pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed four other people with a new
idea that I had so when the idea was
first suggested to me about doing this
and reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay
it's gonna require an ask I might get
rejected it may not work out and I had
it scheduled for today because today was
my YouTube day and so I look at the list
today and like ah maybe I should start
with one person or two people or just
pick the easy people and just the fact
that I felt that just the fact that that
was one of the reasons meant I had to go
and do five I had to do a bigger number
I had to go after the harder people I
had to do the people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
going to care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there that negative voice inside your
head that's telling you that you suck
and you can't do it that's not your
voice that's not actually your voice
that's not you telling yourself that you
suck that voice was planted there that
voice was put there by somebody else